il être avec tout vous êtes membre du
haut conseil pour le climat c'est vous
qui avait d'une certaine manière initié
la fameuse taxe carbone est ce que
d'abord c'est une bonne idée ça ce qu'on
vient de dire de réguler le transport
aérien le conseil pour le climat n'a
absolument pas initier la taxe carbone
âge le précise sabrou pardonne cette
erreur alors danser à titre personnel
oui c'est un truc sur lequel j'ai
raconté des choses mais pas l'eau ainsi
pour le qui marche est ce que c'est une
bonne idée réguler le transport aérien
alors je vais élargir un tout petit peu
le propos
si on veut tenir les deux degrés de
réchauffement maximum en ce qui concerne
l optima planétaire d'ici à 2100
exactement depuis des valeurs
industrielles jusqu'à 2100 l'ordre de
grandeur qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
qu'il faut que les émissions planétaires
baisse de 4% par an donc tous les ans il
faut les baisser de 4% par rapport à
l'année précédente
il se trouve que la crise économique que
nous allons vivre cette année dans le
monde va faire baisser les émissions d'à
peu près 4 % donc le rythme de baisse
qu'il faudrait qu'on suit y va pour que
nous limitions le réchauffement
climatique à 2 degrés représenta
qu'ovide supplémentaires tous les ans
voilà c'est ça que je voulais donner
comme ordre de grandeur de départ
alors une fois que je vous ai dit ça
vous comprenez qu'il va falloir tout
faire il va falloir s'occuper de
l'agriculture du trayas et de l'avion
effectivement votre prix votre idée pour
ou après vous aurez votre idée là très
concrètes pour le monde d'après à court
terme ce serait quoi pour vous alors ça
des idées j'en ai plein il y en a pas
une qui soit plus importante qu'une
autre à partir du moment où on a affaire
à un système une idée importante c'est
que malheureusement on va devoir
apprendre à vivre en récession une idée
importante c'est que qu'on va comment
dire devoir apprendre à faire des choix
une idée importante c'est qu'il va
falloir que les villes dégonfle une idée
importante c'est qu'il va falloir mettre
du monde dans l'agriculture une idée
importante c'est qu'il va falloir qu'on
apprenne à ralentir nos déplacements et
à les payer plus cher il ya plein
d'idées importante donc je de temps dans
quelque chose dans un système vous
pouvez pas dire qu'il ya une idée qui
est plus importante qu'une autre
ça veut dire qu'il faut faire des choix
par exemple pour reprendre l'exemple de
l'aérien et les compagnies aériennes il
faut accepter de ne pas sauver toutes
les compagnies aériennes après la crise
et des choix ont en effet déjà
il faudrait idéalement ne peut pas les
sauver pour une fois pas souri
il faudrait idéalement leur demander des
contreparties au moment où les sauve
parce que de toute façon elles ne vont
pas pouvoir repartir de l'avant
comme c'était le cas avant cette crise
il ya une chose qu'il faut pas oublier
en ce qui concerne l'avion c'est qu'un
avion ça consomme du pétrole or il se
trouve que le maximum historique de
production de pétrole dans le monde
à date c'est énervant pour 2018 depuis
sa ré commencé à baisser et avec le prix
du baril est que nous avons en ce moment
la production de pétrole va
considérablement baissé dans l'année qui
vient
manière significative et derrière el
papa repartir à la hausse de manière
faramineuses dom avant avec de moins en
moins de pétrole de toute façon il va
bien falloir que les usages du pétrole
baissent mais qu'est ce qu'on dit à tous
les salariés de ces compagnies aériennes
de ma basse et finir en janvier on leur
dit une première chose c'est qu'on leur
dit que leurs dirigeants ont été
imprévoyant parce que ce que je vous dis
là c'est des choses qui sont connues
depuis des années et on est dans un déni
collectif depuis le savez il ya des tas
de trucs qu'on aime pas on n'aime pas ce
qu'on vieillit on n'aime pas savoir
qu'on va devoir payer des grosses
charges etc
il ya un truc un dirigeant d'entreprise
a horreur d'entendre c'est que ça va
aller mal dans son secteur
ça va être dur dans son secteur donc du
coup les dirigeants des compagnies
aériennes jusqu'à maintenant ont cru et
du reste quand vous regardez les plans à
50 ans il ya que de la croissance pour
les 50 ans qui viennent
donc il ya rien de prêt pour le contexte
que nous allons vivre rien donc on va
devoir bricoler à court terme une chose
qui est sûre c'est que la femme on
parlait tout à l'heure d'une idée
importante
la première des idées importantes c'est
de ne pas se voiler la face
quand on sait qu'on va avoir quelque
chose de difficile devant soi bien merci
pour ces quelques mots et ses
propositions vous en avez beaucoup
effectivement merci infiniment